I'm here with Pete Holmes we're shooting
the promos I was we're gonna work out
I'm gonna be doing finding out that we
have similar skills no chemistry lacking
we talk over each other it calms things
down mistake a lot of mistakes have been
made no common ground no flags
Flagstaff that an expression that even
that makes no sense there's no flags
people say that TBS we know drama no
that's TNT TNT we know characters and
they're welcome know TBS we're funny is
it weird funny we're funny or no it's
very funny they're very clear that we're
not funny they've made that clear the
real moment that was a legal stipulation
we don't click the way people should
click who follow one another please do
touch oh sorry
don't touch that I'm so cold yeah I saw
my future Wow I eat Souls I've been in
this business a long time yeah so this
whole time I've had my chest out and my
hands back but your posture yeah was
you're out here was down here and you
look like a slowly melting candle but
I'm like a Greek god all right this will
help you in your monologue don't do that
I'm doing what you just did have you had
any training I had years and years of
training before I had my talk show no
hundreds and hundreds of thousands of
hours it's not true rigorous wind test
you got the call while you were writing
on The Simpsons and yes I did and I was
on the air eleven minutes later for the
first all of 1993-94 I look like they
had just thrown an old squirrel into a
trash can and filmed it it was pretty
much that's what the footage is me
running around I have to think that even
if even if we have some growing pains
it'll be interesting to watch it was
interesting to watch with you else
you're admitting that were growing pains
no you have this is over I had a show on
TBS and then I blew it during the promo